let's pull up this story here from The
Daily Mail it's because of the left all
these stories The Daily Mail is where
it's at I mean they've written up every
single thing and they've got photos of
everything when it comes to this story
very few Outlets are covering the antifa
terror attack poor little rich boy
smirking suspected anti-fagoon who
helped attack Georgia cop city as son of
NYC plastic Furniture Tycoon he and his
22 cronies appear in court on terror
charges
so not only are these people many of
them from out of state some
International they're rich kids yeah
yeah but here's go ahead no no I was
gonna yeah go ahead I was gonna say this
is another example of it ties into the
earlier conversation and comment on it
the biggest problem I have right now is
a two-tier system of justice and that's
the biggest argument we need to advance
not the Q Anon Shannon whatever that
guy's name is or certain videos
depicting X Y and Z but use it as a
vehicle to say look at how
differently you can be treated by the
justices in the United States of America
depending on your political orientation
go back to the antifa Riots of not last
summer but summer before that two uh
liberal attorneys
white shoe lawyers firebombed a New York
City police car and burned it to the
ground with Molotov cocktails and the
judge literally a good guy good guy
Federal so they were charged obviously
rightfully so as a federal prosecutor
Federal public defender who defended
people who did that stuff that's a
10-year minimum mandatory federal prison
sentence you know what this doj did
waived the charges allowed the judge to
go under the mid-man and gave him
basically probation
that's a two-tier system of justice mark
my word it's going to happen with this
so Ian just a moment ago said that he's
finding himself becoming more
conservative but I think the reality is
in today today's politics conservative
just means knowledgeable yeah yeah
because because like I'm not more
pro-life or anything right the opinions
of everyone in this room are not in
complete alignment on core policy issues
they're in alignment on the facts that's
it yeah it's the mobs attacking people
that I'm it's kind of my my main issue I
don't like that stuff I found that video
if you guys want to pull it up from
yalen I typed attack restaurant and
Twitter and it popped up yeah yeah how
do you pronounce it I mean how do you
spell that it's the Twitter account is
y-c-i-n-n
ew oh I found it yeah Tim to your point
we live in the lobby I'll pull that up
in a second we live in the logic of
Herbert Marquees I've said this a bunch
it is it is we live in the uh the logic
of of the left is okay to do whatever
they want and the right must be censored
even at the level of thought but how and
and it's because people are scared of
the left yeah but yeah cash I fully
agree with you but how do we do that I
mean I guess since the dawn of time I
imagine the king's uh uh you know
enforcement arm doesn't prosecute him
because and as a leader when are you
gonna be like I'm under arrest you know
like no lead or whatever that I've ever
heard of would do that to themself
um but what what how would we do that
how would we prevent
multiple tiers of Justice from
coexisting and assessing okay it's a
massive overhaul one you have to control
the executive branch of government
install an attorney general in the
layers below him to eliminate
Prosecuting People based on religious
orientation or political orientation
like the rescinded FBI memo uh from last
week that showed that the FBI was
literally targeting Catholics in order
to do that you have to wipe out the FBI
I've always said this the best way and
wipe out the FBI I mean the FBI
headquarters component right the biggest
problem in government is these monster
headquarters components the FBI
headquarters building is the size of a
New York City square block what I would
do if I was FBI director in the next
Trump Administration is close down the
Hoover building and make it a free
Monumental museum for the Deep State on
how not to run government and allow the
world to go there for free I'm not
saying you don't need 50 people running
the FBI you do
but you take the 10 000 agents that are
stuck there and they're lawyers and you
send them into the field to investigate
child sex crimes bank robberies cartels
fraud and you do the same thing with the
doj headquarters building which is just
across the street and just as big why do
you need 5 000 lawyers in one place
telling you how to not do something or
how to politically motivate your bosses
and say and get them something that they
just I worked with all these guys all
these guys that are producing these
charges at doj for Jan six are literally
people that I used to work with who have
sent me subpoenas for January 6th
literally sent me to the Grand Jury
asking me about why I helped participate
in X Y and Z and I'm like dude I was
literally there with you Prosecuting
terrorists and you're doing this because
I've been labeled a trump guy and you
need to make yourself look good in front
of your boss you have to wipe out all of
this Personnel uh Charlie Kirk said the
similar thing about the RNC
decentralizing it getting that big
Central because what they do is they
have lunch meetings there then they go
over on K Street and they hang out and
they all had a little all that forms
because it's so easy but if they were
far away from each other then it becomes
a challenge to uh collaborate but you
also make people do like I every look 98
of the guys I served with at the FBI
want to go out and Chase bank robbers
and Chase down terrorists and take out
people who are harming children and
reduce the drug trade you know there's a
couple of Bad actors and you've got to
eliminate them the problem is they want
to go go after terrorists but then the
upper level like the top floor is
telling them that American like
Catholics are and they go along and
that's why you have to wipe out both you
have decentralized wipe out not just the
upper level that's it's not just the AG
and the director abolish demolish the
building you got to be the under
secretaries but and everything else if
these people are willing to go along
with it they're part of the problem I
totally agree and they shouldn't be in
there I mean this is the Genesis of my
book government gangsters which this
government won't let me release right
now but the whole point is you can go
out there
whether it's DOD nsaci FBI and I take
Flack for this all the time and I'm like
yeah it is not an easy fix but there
used to be a day when the FBI was just
the FBI and doj was just the doj
prosecuting based on facts and law well
not politics and religion I saw a video
this morning
so uh I wake up and I what was it I
think I got I got a clip sent to me by
Sheamus of Freedom tunes and it's a
funny fouchy cartoon and then as soon as
the cartoon ends it rolls over to
another video of Police pulling over a
19 year old football player and falsely
charging him with a DUI and you can even
see after he blows the breathalyzer and
the body camera footage it says zero
zero zero why did they do that why why
did this 19 year old kid who was
watching football game driving home who
did nothing wrong other than hit a
headlight outside his bright sun it's
like a normal thing it happens people
your lights go out you're like well turn
the brights on why why
charge him with a DUI
and so the problem is
I see things like this
that a police officer falsely accuses a
teenager of a DUI but
and and
the police will run in Terror like
pathetic whiny crybabies when antifa
sets fire to their building in Minnesota
they won't arrest these people we can
watch a video of 150 antifa fire bombing
a government facility and of course
there there were 20 to 30 people getting
arrested but when you look at Portland
the cops just sit there and go well you
know go gee but you'll we see
why is it that we have too many
instances of police giving up BS tickets
and making false arrests but we don't
have too many videos of cops just
arresting antifa well now we at least
this thing in Georgia I love this this
situation I hate it because it was a
horrible thing to firebomb a group of
people to firebomb a police facility but
it was great that they responded not by
murdering people
issuing 35 arrests and charging 23
people like that's the way the covet
history is over for the most part now
it's like in fact I think in one city
the governor or the mayor Adams in New
York was saying take your masks off
before you go shopping I don't want you
going in there threatening thuggery he
said stores have to tell people to move
their masks
New York City is saying take your mask
off I have to wonder cash if everything
I said before about people being too
stupid it's in fact that the leadership
is as stupid right of course the
leadership is no no the leadership is
evil they're not stupid there's a
distinction I've worked with all of
these people they are pure evil the only
thing the Pelosi's and the schumers and
the and they'll like care about in the
world is being glorified in the media
that's it what's my next headline what's
my next payday how do I scam the stock
market with my husband how do I come out
on top and be speaker of the house for
more than basically a decade that is the
tract that people come in behind them on
and saying I want to be the next turn I
want to be the next them they are evil
that's the problem the people that
follow them yes stupid I love that bit
you met you mentioned term limits
earlier Phil before the show got started
do you think that would solve or at
least disincentivize evil term limits on
the bureaucracy
I think the bureaucracy is the problem I
think that the the elected officials are
not I think the elected officials are
self-centered and self-serving and that
they do mostly do things to benefit
themselves I think that the bureaucracy
is where the real power is and I think
the bureaucracy is the biggest problem
in the United States like the head of
the FBI any of the any of the alphabet
soup uh agencies so your EPA your FBI
your CIA your your ATF your uh FDA
you're all of them the reason is because
they make law with they make rules that
have the effect of law with no
repercussions from the population from
the voting populace so we talk about how
it's important that we're done you know
we're democracy but the people that make
the rules that you live by on a
day-to-day basis are almost always
unelected so the the government will
decide we want to pass this law and then
whatever agency that has jurisdiction
over the law or whatever the topic is
they will make the actual rules and the
details to implement the law so that's a
whole layer of legislation creation that
the population basically doesn't have
any access to has no ability to punish
them if they do something wrong so what
you're talking about is like the beef
patty of your burger yeah that's 100
Patty of the deep State I agree that's a
novel concept that a lot of people
aren't talking about the FBI directors
and CI directors all have term limits
they're gone with every Administration
right some should be shorter that's a
different argument but these people
you're talking about other ones that sit
there and say I don't care who the
leader is I'm going to do what we want
to do what the political radical left
agenda is because it's the popular one
and they stay and convince the
leadership to do it and Goose it through
the system that was one of the biggest
problems in the Trump Administration and
one more thing to your point is it's not
just I understand and I agree that there
are evil people but there are there's
also something that Tim talks about the
banality of evil there are people that
just go to work and want to go and make
sure that they can go on vacation with
their wife and they want to just make
sure their kids can go to school and get
a good education and they come out of
school and they can get good jobs for
themselves and they just want to live a
normal life so what they want to do is
go to work and not make waves and you
know what makes waves voting for Donald
Trump thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time